dans ses voeux pour la nouvelle année le
président russe vladimir poutine a
appelé à la cohésion face au co vide 19
ou biche d'or
je suis convaincu qu'ensemble nous
parviendront à surmonter tout ça pour
revenir à une vie normale et avec une
énergie renouvelée continuer à résoudre
les défis auxquels la russie sera
confrontée pour cette troisième décennie
à venir du 21e siècle une cohésion
également nécessaire dans l'immense défi
de la campagne de vaccination dans le
monde
campagne à laquelle la russie participe
activement son vaccin spoutnik v étant
distribué dans de nombreux pays
cinquante états auraient d'ores et déjà
passé commande pour acquérir le vaccin
russe l'argentine a été le tout premier
état d'amérique latine a déployé le
vaccin sur son territoire cela nous
rassure un peu de penser que c'est le
début de la fin de cette situation
vraiment étrange et nous attendions ça
depuis tellement longtemps de juste
essayé de franchir une première étape
pour en finir avec ce virus
je suis vraiment très fier sur le
continent sud-américain également l'état
brésilien de bahia harkis près de 50
millions de doses du spoutnik vais le
mexique le venezuela et la colombie ont
également passé commande auprès de
moscou ainsi que la bolivie
avec cet accord nous avons une garantie
pour 5,2 millions de doses pour le
peuple bolivien
la première livraison devrait arriver
officiellement à la fin du mois de mars
avec une quantité dépassant les 1
million 700 mille doses
l'algérie aussi à l'intention de
vacciner sa population à partir du mois
de janvier à l'aide du spoutnik vais en
asie l'inde a commandé 100 millions de
doses le kazakhstan 2 millions la
biélorussie et la serbie ou encore la
hongrie sont encore d'autres pays à
avoir passé un contrat avec moscou
ces derniers jours des lots importants
de spoutnik v sont donc envoyés aux
quatre coins du globe
en tout 1 milliard de doses sont pour
l'heure prévue à l'exportation